I have a really sort of boneheaded clip
to play for you today from a Republican
senator from Florida Rick Scott and the
clip is interesting but really it's
going to serve as a kind of jumping-off
point for us to talk about really some
of the basics of how the American
economy is organized and how it is
really based on the type of relationship
that we have with China and so the point
of this is for us to better understand
why Donald Trump's critique of the
us-china trade relationship is so wrong
and so misguided and you really can't
understand that unless you understand
some of what we're going to talk about
here so as many of you know you've
probably heard Trump say and it's true
the United States imports a ton of stuff
from China this includes raw materials
this includes finished electronic
products and other products and we don't
export as much to China as we import
from China meaning we have a trade
deficit with China the obvious reasons
why this is the situation include labor
is cheaper in China the weaker
regulatory environment in China also
makes it financially advantageous to do
this that's all true but there's really
a lot more to this that we have to
understand so to set the conversation
here's Florida senator Rick Scott he's a
Republican of course saying nobody in
the united states should be buying stuff
from communist China let's look at what
he had to say I believe this was
yesterday or the day before on the floor
of the Senate which prohibits the u.s.
government from purchasing drones
manufactured in countries identified as
national security threats like Iran and
China we know Commons China steals their
technology and intellectual parklet
property yet the US government continues
to buy critical technology like drones
with American tax dollars from Chinese
companies backed by their government no
one in America should buy products made
in communist China especially not the US
government we cannot continue this
practice and my American security drone
act is a common-sense solution to end
this threat to our national security so
what these
and to be honest many Democrats get this
wrong as well what is being missed about
the China trade conversations so often
is that our trade deficit with China and
China holding so much American debt as
they do through bonds this is not a bug
in the system we might not like it but
it's a feature of how this the system is
designed and and I'll explain to you
what that means
collectively the United States decided
implicitly the United States decided
decades ago that we value cheap products
from China more than we value domestic
production we don't want to pay more for
stuff that's made in the United States
when I say we you might be ok with it
but as a country in organizing our
economy our leaders have decided we want
the cheap stuff from China so our entire
economy is based around specialization
and this includes exporting services
like we increasingly do to China but
importing products products that have
been made in China because the demand
for these products is so high and many
of these products would not be
affordable to everyday Americans if they
were manufactured in the United States
now that's because of a whole other set
of problems but if we're going to talk
about the us-china trade relationship we
have to sort of set this basic
understanding so naturally this means
we're going to import more stuff from
China then we're going to export and
that's where you get a trade deficit
that's the trade deficit Trump refers to
and many Republicans refer to now when
you hear the word deficit it sounds bad
it's meant to sound bad because we think
Oh deficits bad surplus is good if you
think about your household economy your
household budget you want to be running
a surplus you want to have something
left over at the end of the month rather
than than to be deficit spending
charging stuff at the end of the month
with the trade relationship it's not
deficit bad surplus good necessarily we
run a trade deficit by design because of
how we've organized the economy to
depend on that cheap stuff from China so
everybody in the US can afford more
stuff instead of less stuff and part of
what keeps China competitive in the
context is that they set the value of
their currency relative to the dollar
using what's called a modified fixed
exchange rate which basically means if
the dollar loses value China will start
buying dollars through bonds this is how
China ends up holding so much of our
debt because they want to keep that
exchange rate between the dollar and the
yuan roughly the same now over the last
few years China has reduced the degree
to which they do this but part of why
China is buying so many bonds and
holding so much of our debt is because
of this trade relationship that we
decided we wanted in order to keep the
flow of cheap Chinese stuff coming to
the United States now I think it's a
good moment to mention you here the
right always go crazy China owns us
china owns our debt Japan actually holds
more of our debt than China but for
political reasons you don't really hear
much about that Japan's just not
considered a threat in the same way that
China is because their economy is a
different type of economy but the point
here is we as a country we as an economy
could decide we don't want to import
stuff from China anymore we don't like
the political idea of importing stuff
from China we don't like the economic
idea as Rick Scott said let's stop
buying from Communist China we could do
that if we wanted but you have to
understand that specialization and trade
including with China in total have
created more jobs in the United States
than have been destroyed due to
outsourcing we've given tens of millions
of Americans access to products which we
now take for granted so I'm not
defending it what I'm saying is if we
want to have the conversation of no
longer having a trade deficit with China
of no longer buying stuff from Communist
China as Rick Scott says we can do that
it would have massive consequences here
in the United States things would get
more expensive a lot of people would
lose jobs but we might decide that in
the long run it's worth it but if we're
going to have this conversation we have
to have the full conversation because we
have the
Phantasy conversation where Trump says
get rid of the trade deficit Rick Scott
says don't buy stuff from Communist
China and people end up coming away with
this idea that we could just stop buying
from China manufactured domestically and
the economy would be otherwise
unaffected other than we've brought jobs
home or whatever the case may be that's
not the reality so I'm not saying what
would be right or wrong what I'm
pointing out is we have decades of
economic policy built upon the
foundation of we value the flow of cheap
goods from China more than we value a
lot of other things that we could value
in the economy don't allow Republicans
like Rick Scott and Trump and even some
Democrats who don't really understand
this don't let them oversimplify this
into stupidity with let's just end the
trade deficit type of stuff because we
have decades of implicit and explicit
decisions built upon we want to keep the
free I'm sorry we want to keep the cheap
stuff coming from China okay we have an
example today this is not me patting
myself on the back but we have an
example today of exactly what I warned
you about a couple months ago when I did
a story about populism versus social
democracy I did a story called
social democracy is being destroyed by
populism this was a little while ago and
I warned you about how the rhetoric of
populism can sound very good
it can even sound like it's uniting left
and right in favor of the middle class
or whatever but that the language can so
easily be used to bamboozle and trick
people Trump used populist rhetoric in
2016
Trump tricked many on the right and some
on the left with his populist rhetoric
in 20 2016 and we are now seeing the
repercussions of that in the current
administration so I have an example for
you today from Tucker Carlson which is
exactly what I was warning about there's
more and more left wingers that are sort
of sympathetic to Tucker Carlson who
FoxNews propagandist because Tucker has
been increasingly using the language of
populism which sometimes sounds
reasonable to hide his horrible policy
ideas sometimes Tucker you turn it on it
sounds like a white nationalist show and
then sometimes you turn it on like last
night or the night before and you hear
tucker using pretty uncontroversial
populist language which could be
implemented with right-wing policy or it
could be implemented with left-wing
policy and he did it again this week and
there are people on the people on the
right of course but there's even
leftists just gushing about look at the
common sense that we're hearing here
from Tucker Carlson and it's painful to
see people fall for it I warned you
about this in my segment recently let's
take a look at the clip forget that in
the end the Republican Party exists to
serve the interests of normal people
ordinary people middle-class families
are the core of this country they are
hope for the future our only hope and
yet both parties have shamelessly
abandoned them middle-class families
have no national spokesman they have no
lobby in Washington Republicans pretend
to be their champion you know by now
that they are not instead of improving
the lives of their voters the party
feeds them a steady diet of mindless
symbolic victories partisan junk food
designed to make them feel full even as
they waste away who cares how many
Benghazi hearings we have we're supposed
to care why should we how did Peter
Struck's text messages become more
important than saving American jobs from
foreign nationals who are taking them it
is lunacy we fall for it every time and
to the extent this show has participated
in it
we apologize with deepest sincerity so
this is classic populist rhetoric that
is very similar on the left and right
Federico Finkelstein from the new school
is very very good he's one of the
foremost experts on left versus right
wing populism and we have looked at so
many examples of rhetoric that is
populist rhetoric which sounds like it
could be coming from a leftist or from a
lunatic right winger the part
here tucker is saying the republican
party should be serving the middle class
you hear democrats sometimes use similar
rhetoric we should be primarily serving
the middle class the middle class is the
core of the country politicians should
focus on improving the lives of voters
he even mentions tucker does the
silliness of Benghazi hearing after
Benghazi hearing and Peter strux
texts and it's true that was nonsense
jobs matter more like he's saying things
that are true but he can't even suppress
the right-wing xenophobia he can't hold
it back because he says hey we we need
the Republican Party to protect us from
foreign nationals who have taken our
jobs and that's the bubbling up of that
virulent anti-immigrant Tucker Carlson
that we know who has said immigrants
make our country dirtier and poorer and
this is why the rise of populism on the
left at the exclusion of just a solid
socially Democratic set of ideas is so
dangerous as I've said before social
democracy is less about rhetoric and
it's more about a clear set of policy
ideas including how do we get health
care for everybody
finance education how do we tax people
well how do we do policing there's so
much policy in social democracy when
instead you start seeing populist
rhetoric it can come from the left and
right and it can sound pretty damn good
with no regard to the policies that are
actually being proposed so to be clear
you can have populist rhetoric and
socially Democratic policy okay well I
mean that would be fine but people like
Tucker Carlson and Steve Bannon to some
degree and others they're great at using
just the rhetoric to pull people in to
what in the end at the other side of it
you know they at the end of the rainbow
so to speak is a terrible set of policy
ideas and Tucker couldn't even hide his
dog whistle it's 95 percent reasonable
populist sounding rhetoric with foreign
nationals which basically means hey
we've got to keep those Mexicans out
right that that's what's the policy
prescription at
the end of this so you have to listen
much more carefully because it sounds
good
we also shouldn't underestimate the
effect that Tucker's advertisers
abandoning him might be having on his
rhetoric I don't know that's another
story which we've covered Tucker's
having major problems with advertisers
because of some of the white nationalist
type sounding rants maybe this is
posturing for those purposes I don't
know but the point the idea here is
listen to all my populist sounding
rhetoric but my solutions are xenophobia
to support the middle class
stop immigrants from coming in so on and
so forth as someone said to me on
Twitter this is a shadow tactic it
sounds reasonable you pull them in with
the rhetoric then you drop the seed of
populism when you think no one is
looking and then it's hey you know what
you'd better vote for Republicans or
black lives matter is going to come and
take your house right that's that's the
bamboozle that's the bait and switch
that happens in the end this is a
polished way to tell us Mexicans are
stealing our jobs black lives matter is
going to take your house and we need to
stop everybody so don't fall for this
stuff review that clip that I did about
populism and social democracy because
this was exact there's no better example
of this type of ruse that I warned you
about six weeks ago or whenever I did
that story then in this Tucker Carlson
segment let me know what you think I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman remember that you
can get the entire show in our audio
podcast forum every single day you can
get it on whatever your favorite
podcasting app is whether it's iTunes or
pod catcher or whatever else
Spotify etc get that daily audio podcast
let me know what you think about this
populism social democracy ruse on
Twitter where you can find me at a
Pakman
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world's famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are Georgina
Poole and Hugh O'Hagan Georgina and Hugh
thank you so much for your support and
also thank you to Tom Todd Thomas Todd
who is today's longtime sustaining
member of the day Thomas has been a
member for almost five years
grab a membership join up at join
pakman.com you can use the code 20:20
now to 0 to zero now all one word all
lowercase to save 66% off of the cost of
a membership ok up dr. Anthony Fauci and
other health officials testified
yesterday before the Senate there were a
bunch of high jinks including Senator
Rand Paul getting into an argument with
doctor foul Chi Texas so disliked doctor
foul she's testimony that last night
lieutenant governor in Texas Dan Patrick
went on Fox News and said we're not
going to listen to doctor foul anymore
but if you ask me I'm listening to foul
chew before I'm listening to Dan Patrick
from Texas any days so what did doctor
foul he tell us some of the things he
said were obvious number one doctor foul
she said we are not really doing that
well we are clearly not in control of
the virus and we could have 100,000
cases a day in the United States if
things don't turn around here he is
saying it it is going to be very
disturbing I will guarantee you that
because when you have an outbreak in one
part of the country even though in other
parts of the country they're doing well
they are vulnerable I made that point
very clearly last week at a press
conference we can't just focus on those
areas that are having the surge
it puts the entire country at risk we
are now having 40 plus thousand new
cases a day I would not be surprised if
we go up to a hundred thousand a day if
this does not turn around and so I am
very concerned so this has already
gotten so bad in at least 16 states that
they've paused or reversed some aspects
of the reopening plans the hardest for
the four hardest hit States recently in
terms of cases are Florida Arizona Texas
and California now if you look at growth
rate of cases rather than absolute
numbers you actually see some other
states that are not getting a lot of
attention in terms of percentage growth
each day they are climbing and if the
trend doesn't reverse in 15 or so days
you would have a very different set of
states that is the worst in the country
in terms of new cases and again the the
message is we could just be at the
beginning here if you look at the total
numbers we cumulatively have seen 2.7
million coronavirus cases in the United
States if the 16 states that are
problematic keep increasing their rate
of new cases just even 10% a week which
is we've seen much faster increases and
than that that 2.7 million number in
terms of cumulative cases is going to go
up dramatically and very very quickly
you can run the numbers yourselves if
you look at 15 if you if we get to
15,000 cases a day in Florida 10,000 a
day in Texas in California you start
seeing that these numbers are going to
add up insanely quickly but the
administration has moved on I mean there
the Trump administration is just done
they are talking about reopening they're
talking about return to greatness
they're talking about jobs and stocks
and all of this other stuff we are
having the work of the four worst the
four worst days that we've had since the
beginning in terms of new cases happen
in the last five days understand that
and hilariously or tragically or I don't
even know what to call it
point one of trumps own hotels failed a
coronavirus hygiene audit there's these
rules in terms of hotels of how they're
supposed to be cleaning surfaces are
supposed to be wiped down all of these
different rules Trump International in
Manhattan was one of the hotels that
Inside Edition audited now you know
Inside Edition it's sort of like pseudo
news
but to the extent that they're telling
the truth about this they had a
correspondent check in two rooms
including at from hotel print the
programs logo the Inside Edition logo on
the bed sheets and pillowcases and
towels using a washable spray and you
can only see that the the spray under
ultraviolet light but if the product is
washed or wiped down then it goes away
and then the Inside Edition
correspondent would make it look like
someone slept in the room they would
leave check out check back in and go
back to the same room the following
night so new as far as the hotel knows
this is a new customer a new guest there
should have been a full cleaning done
Trump international reportedly changed
the bed sheets did not change the
pillowcase at all did not wipe down the
desk and other surfaces so clearly the
Trump hotels are not the only ones that
are failing to meet the hygiene
requirements and things are looking very
very ugly in a lot of these industries
but many states are just full steam
ahead so at this point if we ask
ourselves like where is the ray of hope
where where is the possibility it's
really in the medical field and
governor's we have to hope that
governor's will show leadership although
many of them are not we have to hope
that people will take this more
seriously than they've been it's been
months but still a lot of people aren't
taking this seriously and we are putting
a lot of emphasis on the medical science
community that they will develop an
effective treatment something that's
better than just you know 15%
improvement for only the sickest
patients and a vaccine and we're really
waiting on that at this point because
our country has failed now I want to
remind you next
I'm going to talk about parts of the us
that are doing well but there are
countries that have dominated this I
spoke to a friend who lives in Belgium
and is currently in France on a vacation
with her boyfriend things are great
there I mean on public transit
everybody's wearing masks restaurants
are open with fewer tables indoors even
outdoors life has resumed very few cases
now they are doing it and I'm envious of
that I admit it fortunately here in
Massachusetts things are going well but
we are judged by the worst of our
country we are not allowed to travel to
many parts of the world because as a
country we are failing and particularly
with people able to come in and out of
states because that's the Constitution
I'm not denying that we we have to talk
next about the states that are doing
well how long can they actually hold on
because the worse things get in some
parts of the country eventually it's
going to bleed into the states that are
taking this very seriously so let's
discuss that next so this is a
conversation where I want to see what
you think I'm not suggesting I know what
needs to happen I'm not suggesting any
authoritarian tactics by States I just
want to see where you're at on this
issue coronavirus is exploding at the
national level some states are doing
well but when you look at the United
States as a country in total our worst
four days in the United States in terms
of new cases came in the last five days
so you go to the very beginning of the
pandemic the four worst days in terms of
new cases have all happened in the last
week and yet here in Massachusetts we
I'm so thrilled to say we reported zero
deaths yesterday for the first time
since the pandemic started and in fact
New England and New York and New Jersey
this sort of eight state consortium
these are some of the best places to be
right now in terms of the the degree of
reduction in cases and transmission
Vermont had no new cases yesterday New
Hampshire had only 22 Maine had only 34
as I said massachu
it's zero deaths in about a hundred new
cases Connecticut about a hundred and
fifty New York and New Jersey still with
higher case numbers but dramatic
reductions and again relative to their
population the numbers are not quite so
scary so in terms of the consortium our
governor Charlie Baker here has expanded
the no quarantine bubble to include New
York for example now you're gonna be
able to if you travel from New York to
Massachusetts you're not going to be
required to quarantine for 14 days
assuming you meet certain requirements
masks are everywhere as many of you know
I've been in Martha's Vineyard this week
people everybody's just wearing masks
you go everywhere it's mask mask mask
you're not going anywhere and seeing
people without them but look at what's
happening elsewhere you've got these
huge swaths of red states plus
California which are seeing record cases
you've got California Texas Florida
Arizona Georgia the Carolinas Tennessee
Louisiana Alabama Ohio and at some point
you're only going to keep that
walled-off for so long at some point if
the cases keep exploding in certain
parts of the country the cases will
start going up here in the Northeast you
you have flights between these parts of
the country so-called mandatory
quarantines are really tough to enforce
and people know it people aren't doing
it so does the Northeast need to do
something because we're hopefully
looking at being able to safely open
schools in the fall and do more but if
the cases start bleeding over from the
more disastrous parts of the country
it's going to ruin the work we've been
doing for months at this point again
reminder I played this clip earlier I'll
play it again doctor foul she is talking
about 100,000 new cases a day in the
u.s. if things don't turn around
he says the infection rate is out of
control in some parts of the country
take a look at this clip one more time
it is going to be very disturbing I will
guarantee you that because when you have
an outbreak in one part of the country
even though in other parts of the
country they're doing well they are
vulnerable I made that point very
clearly last week at a press conference
we can't just focus on those areas that
are having the surge it puts the entire
country at
risk we are now having 40 plus thousand
new cases a day I would not be surprised
if we go up to a hundred thousand a day
if this does not turn around and so I am
very concerned so what should the
northeast do I mean legally this is
difficult the Constitution grants
ingress and egress to and from States
and I am not proposing that we violate
the Constitution airlines have shown
they are committed to having more
flights and having flights be more full
so I don't know what if anything can be
done but if cases continue to explode to
this degree in some parts of the country
eventually the pandemics going to come
back to the Northeast because people are
traveling people are ignoring quarantine
can you do roadblocks but not to stop
people from coming in merely to register
that they are coming in and ask them
where will you be quarantine you still
can't really enforce it you don't have
the resources but maybe if people go
through that they would be more mindful
and maybe be more likely to stick to the
required quarantine I don't know it's
obviously beyond the resources of any
state to really enforce it so I have no
idea my question to you is what should
be done we are beyond the early hotspot
phase the early hotspot phase was based
on flights and and the earlier spots of
contagion you had hot spots it's now
based on policy the places with the
better policy are doing better the
places with the looser policy are doing
worse what should be done should the
Northeast do anything let me know what
you think and we'll have more coverage
of this on our Instagram page at David
Pakman show make sure you're following
us there
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on the support of our viewers and
listeners and one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month or as
much as you want at patreon.com slash
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him welcome
back to the David Pakman show it is
great to welcome to the program today
Phil Gorski who's a 30 year Canadian
intelligence veteran author of five
books on terrorism and also host of the
podcast an intelligent look at terrorism
Phil it's great to have you on today hey
it's great to be here David thanks for
inviting me on the show so I mean where
to start right I guess the the war on
terror has now been waged for decades
how is it going are we winning it yet no
we're not and you know you referenced
the fact that I've written five books my
fourth book was actually entitled an end
to the war on terrorism I hate the term
I've hated it since day one as you noted
in your introduction I worked in
security intelligence for that so for
the Canadian Security Intelligence
Service kind of like an FBI CIA hybrid
we looked at homegrown plots Canadians
traveling to join al-qaeda later Isis
etc al-shabaab in Somalia and yet were
framing us through the military and the
problem is as a American academic said
very wisely after 9/11 he says whatever
you do don't declare war on a common
noun because it never ends think of the
war on drugs in your country think on
the war and poverty think on the war on
any common down because you said common
nouns don't surrender whereas proper
nouns do so you ask me how's it going
it's going well and not so well well in
a sense that in your country in mine
we're not seeing terrorist attacks on a
regular basis let's face it that's that
that's true and yet if you look at the
news
on any given day David which I do as a
regular course he's no I'm retired I'm
still involved in this business every
day in Afghanistan Somalia or Nigeria or
Iraq or Syria there's an attack and in
several cases many attacks per day in
those countries so it's going both well
and not so well depending on your
perspective I guess here in the United
States there is an interesting report
from the anti-defamation league which
I've referenced before which looked at a
politically based domestic terror
killings so to speak and they are
overwhelmingly right-wing the numbers
are as I recall I think in 2019 were 76%
right-wing 20% Islamic extremism and
then 4% left or sort of miscellaneous
now from from a logistical perspective
when I hear that someone believes their
religion should be the law of the land
and is willing to kill for those reasons
to me that sounds right wing's so when I
think of Islamic extremism it's often
framed as left-wing it sounds really
right-wing to me in the intelligence
community is there a position on that on
the characterization of Islamic violence
Wow we certainly looked at is the most
extremism as our number one threat we
had several plots in the 2000s in the
2010s several hundred Canadians went to
join Isis etc etc we had a small
right-wing desk which frankly wasn't
very busy when I retired in 2015 I'm
sure it's busier right now I would push
back a little bit of those stats it's
true that in your country obviously the
far right is about two-thirds or
three-quarters of the incidents yeah
around the world is still 95 percent is
the most extremism these are the numbers
across the world no denial whatsoever
yeah yeah the way you framed it is
really interesting so I did write a book
by last book was entitled win religions
kill and I looked at how every religion
has within it an extreme element that
justifies killing in the name of God
Judaism Christianity even Buddhism my
god a Buddhist extremist should be an
oxymoron and yet there are Buddhist
terrorists in Sri Lanka in Thailand and
Myanmar
I guess she would say that is the most
extremist are conservative they're
definitely very intolerant the view of
Islam that they try to force on people
collusion Airi essentially it's my way
or the highway Bernard Lewis the
American academic academic said very
famously after 9/11 it's like as I'm
right you're wrong
go to hell that's the way these people
see the world so I guess I'm at
perspective we would look at it as right
wing but from my experience working in
the Canadian intelligence community it
was his own separate task and it was the
lion's share of the counterterrorism
work for their better part of the 20
years you just referred to in the post
9/11 period when we think about the
radicalization of individuals when I've
interviewed domestic extremists in the
United States like former KKK and white
nationalists and others almost
exclusively there's a story of there was
a lack of empathy and support in their
lives which led them vulnerable to sort
of join up with whoever paid them
attention and accept the orthodoxy that
they presented in an international
terror and the work that you did
is it a similar pattern what leads to
the radicalization of an individual Wow
how much time do we have I mean my very
first book from within looked at that
and I was basing on cases I worked in
Canada unclassified information
obviously but we found the opposite
David we found that these people were
run-of-the-mill average Canadians they
were averaged from a socio-economic
status they were averaged from an
educational background
they were averaged from a family
background they were averaged in so far
as we could tell we're not psychologists
from a mental health perspective there
was nothing that sort of divided them or
separated them from the general Canadian
populace and I've seen the same stats
for the United States as well in terms
of Islamist extremism I do think that we
look at the far-right KKK you know the
Boogaloo boys you might see that kind of
a bit of a tendency towards the
down-and-out in life you know you often
hear the term marginalized you hear the
term not making ends meet you know
failing in education failing at
relationships failing at at work you'll
see none of the ism aside but of course
you have exceptions you look at a
country like France yeah and a lot of
the people who join Isis and al-qaida in
France are on the lower socioeconomic
spectrum but I would argue you look at
French Muslim society in general
it's generally speaking gets on the
lower you know your country and my
country are very different Muslims in
our country have time to tend to do very
very well they tend to be highly
educated they tend to be have good jobs
solid families etc in Europe that's not
the case for all kinds of historical
reasons
bottom line David is that there's no
profile to any of this and people that
try to profile get into trouble because
we do try to profile you run into two
problems yes well one is what I call a
false positive if you think that all
jihadis are all right when guys are X
and somebody's is X and it's not a
jihadi that's a problem and then if you
say that no jihadi czar well educated or
no KK care well educated the first guy
with a PhD you don't look at because he
doesn't fit your profile so when we
worked at when I worked for the Canadian
Security Intelligence Service we didn't
have a profile we looked at activity we
looked at you know online statements
which we had warrants to intercept we
looked at what they said and what they
did not who they were where they came
from or what their particular
circumstances were and I think that was
the SiC that was successful for us when
it comes to the leaders of terrorist
organizations over the last 20 years
we've all seen endless headlines of the
number two was killed the number three
you know whatever yeah how how important
is that to actually fighting terror and
I'll make the question sort of a
two-part question
one if what we're fighting is an
ideology is the ideology affected by
killing an individual is it sometimes
sometimes yes sometimes no okay and then
number two even from the operational
standpoint how effective is it to kill
the number one the number two the number
three guy I can give you an answer
you're not going to like it depends okay
so so in some groups it's all about the
leader the group a group like Shining
Path the sedona Luminoso in Peru when
Guzman was taken by the Peruvians back
in the early 90s the group never really
recovered they're still around but
they're a shadow of their former selves
you look at al-qaeda bin Laden's gone
now Ayman al-zawahri can't hold a candle
to bin Laden from a charismatic
perspective he's the he's like watching
paint dry
and he all Qaeda is still around we got
Baghdady
right a couple years ago you guys got
back daddy Isis is just as strong if not
stronger than it ever was
I better cases maybe the PKK in Turkey
the Kurdish militant group the Turks
count captrick abdullah al july back in
nineteen
94 he's been in prison on an island in
Turkey for the better part of over 20
years the cake the PKK is carrying out
attacks on a weekly basis in eastern
Turkey so the short answer is it depends
on the nature of the group and the
controller which the leader has against
within that group the second part of
your question is look it's never a bad
thing to take out a major terrorist we
always used to say a dead terrorist is a
good terrorist you don't have to
investigate them anymore you don't have
worry about him he can't exert his
influence at cetera et cetera now we can
argue about rule of law and whether or
not extraterritorial assassinations are
legal that's a whole other discussion
so taking guys out is never a bad thing
the problem is it rarely if ever means
the end and I'm tired of reading
headlines
you know we've got so and so this is the
end of group number X X Y or Z it never
is or very rarely is because as you
mentioned is the ideology that's
important not the individual the
individual can be charismatic attract
people retain people inspire people
but charismatic people are sometimes a
dime a dozen is the ideology that
matters that's what you have to
undermine and that's a lot more
difficult to carry you can't carry a
drone strike against an ideology
unfortunately I want to get back to that
but because you mentioned you know the
question as to the legality of
extraterritorial killings of suspected
terrorists in the work you did did that
play at all in in your work or is that
sort of like that was handled the the
legal questions were are handled
somewhere else
absolutely so we're essentially we were
essentially a domestic intelligence
service but we had an international
agreement because Canadians were
fighting with the Taliban and all kind
of things like that
we had lawyers obviously that you were
able to guide us but we follow the law
in a sense that we went to court to get
warrants to intercept people's
communications you have to do that you
can't you know follow somebody up and go
on Twitter or intercept it because
that's the illegal in Canada so from our
perspective we provided intelligence and
you provide it to decision makers now
sometimes the decision makers might be
in the Canadian military or the US
military and they will decide to do
without intelligence whatever that their
mandate says that they can do
I didn't lose sleep at night personally
about my intelligence being used in a
way that I might not necessarily agree
with from my own ethical perspective
because first of all a can is a pretty
small player right we
carrying out drone strikes that you guys
are in Yemen and Afghanistan and and and
Somalia so if not perspective it wasn't
as important I do think there's a bigger
conversation around this and I know what
that when an oral al-awlaki who was the
American who was killed in Yemen a
couple years ago that raised a real
kerfuffle at your country because he was
an American citizen and didn't get his
day in court right he was yes - to
refute the charges against him
I didn't lose sleep over Al lucky
because he was a major instigator he was
a major charismatic leader of al Qaeda
in Arabian Peninsula there wasn't a
single Canadian that didn't follow his
writings or his videos online so him
disappearing was it was a good good news
day for us but on the other side of the
coin I do understand the legal
ramifications of it but when you work in
intelligence you provide the best
information you can to those that can
use it and you do so to the best of your
ability okay so now that that being kind
of framed in terms of your work when we
think about what does work to root out
an ideology I mean is it one one area
that doesn't seem to be discussed enough
is sort of the economic situation in the
source countries and when we talk about
undocumented immigration here in the
United States you know the current
administration talks about walls and
they talk about you know jail and all
this stuff if the economic circumstances
were better in the source countries the
demand for trying to come to the United
States illegally would would decrease
dramatically can does that apply to
thinking about the ideologies that rise
and the way in which people can be
indoctrinated can that be separated from
the context in which these countries are
existing yeah you're asking early tough
questions for me on Canada Day ah that's
a tough one again it depends because if
you look at 9/11 for example 15 of the
19 hijackers that attacked in New York
and Washington were rich Saudi
individuals they don't have any
socio-economic problems I do think that
it obviously makes sense from a
humanitarian and global stability
perspective to make sure that every
country is as economically feasible and
and workable as possible and yes it
might in fact prevent or convince people
to stay at home rather than come to
Canada United States I mean you know we
take in 1% of our population every year
by immigration we take in 300,000
so that's its 1% your country has a
similar high rate at least it did under
the current president maybe not so much
so I think that put it this way David it
can't hurt but I'm not necessarily
certain that it would be enough to
undermine the ideology the ideology has
to be undermined by the vast majority of
people who live in that greater polity
be it Islam or Buddhism or Hinduism or
judaism whatever who fight against it
who say this is not what we represent
this is not what our faith tells us to
do this is not what the founders of our
religion said there's a good thing to do
it's only those people that can say this
is wrong we're not gonna support it and
we're gonna actively undermine what
you're trying to do that to me and I've
seen it happen here in Canada on a
limited scale that to me is the only way
we're gonna say you'll get rid of the
Islamist extremist ideology or the Hindu
extremist ideology in India which is
very worrisome by the way these days
with what Modi is doing with his support
from very violent Hindu extremists in
any RSS in other parts of Indian society
those the people that have to stand up
with our support and basically talk down
and and and get rid of the ideology that
is being spewed by a very small minority
within their communities that's not
let's not exaggerate this right very
very few people espouse this ideology
that's why I mean that's why when I hear
you saying it has to be made clear by
everybody else that this is not
acceptable it seems that that's already
sort of the case right I mean I guess I
would what you're saying sounds so
intuitive and yet it starts to sound
sort of like you know where where are
all of the moderate Muslims denouncing
this and it's like well they they are
right I mean it's so it starts to get
into sort of dicey territory because
you're already talking about such a
small portion of the population well I
would also counter that you're not gonna
get rid of his ideology it's not gonna
disappear tomorrow
I mean communism which we fought against
I started my career in the Cold War in
1983 there's also Viet Union in Soviet
Union that that founded and yet look
what's happening now in modern Russia
you could argue it's a resurgence of the
Communist ideal or whatever you want to
call it so the ideology is not going to
you know vanish poof one day into the
ether it's always going to be there what
you're trying to do is to make it such
that it's an irritant not an
all-encompassing
sort of I don't know that this obsession
you have it's all terrorism all the time
it's you know it's not all terrorism all
the time in my country I'm actually
researching a book on the history of
terrorism a Canada from Confederation
which is 153 years ago today you know
we've suffered at most 20 attacks in 153
years now mind you we went a century
between attack one an attack two we get
my point right
we're not Afghanistan we're not Somalia
we're not Nigeria we're not Yemen that
is it neither is your country now there
are most countries in Western Europe so
how can we get away from this obsession
about terrorism
let our counterterrorism agencies do
their jobs as well as law enforcement
get citizenry involved to talk these
guys down to to either ignore them or to
counter their views but let's not think
of that weird over subtly existentially
threatened by terrorists this is not
makes essential threat David it is if
you're if you're for an Afghan it's not
if you're an American and that's not if
you're Acadian we've been speaking with
Phil Gorski who's a 30-plus year
Canadian intelligence veteran author of
five books on terrorism also hosts the
podcast an intelligent look at terrorism
Phil I so appreciate your time today my
pleasure Davis maybe we do it again
sometime the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
so all of the lies from the
administration about the Russian bounty
story have completely imploded and
fallen apart and the reason that they've
fallen apart is that even if the lies
were true they would only expose new
problems so let me give you an example
if Trump really hadn't been briefed
about the Russian Bounty's situation
that's the problem why wasn't he briefed
that would be an absolute and total
disaster given that we know the topic
got to the National Security Council if
the Russian Bounty's situation was in
his presidential daily briefing months
ago why doesn't he remember is it a
memory problem that's also a huge
problem in other words the explanations
we've heard so far if true would all
just be indicative of additional new and
even bigger problems and to sort of
reset the story the news broke over the
weekend that there were reportedly
Russian bounties these are like cash
bonuses offered to Taliban linked
fighters if they were able to kill us or
coalition troops in Afghanistan they
would get a cash bonus okay that's
absolutely and utterly insane initially
the White House was silent for I believe
it was 24 hours Trump was not briefed
about it
we were told multiple reports came out
later that Trump had been briefed as
early as 2019 - as recently as spring
and eventually we got to the specific
claim that the bounty report was in his
presidential daily briefing in February
so at a press briefing yesterday Donald
Trump's press secretary Kaylee McKenna
he was asked why isn't Trump reading the
PDB in other words if it was in there
and Trump doesn't know about it
is he not reading it does he not
remember and Caylee goes bonkers
saying Trump is the most informed person
on the planet on issues related to
threats against the United States take a
listen asking me to defend why the
president is necessarily reading of DDD
there are these types of issues that
arise the president does read and he
also consumes intelligence verbally this
president I'll tell you is the most
informed person on planet Earth when it
comes to the threats that we face
you have ambassador O'Brien who sees him
in person twice a day who sometimes
takes the upwards of half a dozen calls
with this president he's constantly
being informed and briefed on
intelligence matters but I'm not going
to allow the New York Times to dictate
when we give top-secret information and
don't give top-secret information the
lie falls apart when you go too far when
Trump once said I'm the least racist
person in the world
it was too hyperbolic right just say
you're not racist it would be not
believable if you're Trump but it would
be more believable than I'm the least
racist person in the world same thing
here Trump is the most informed person
in the world on threats to America he
doesn't even read his own presidential
daily briefings just say he's informed
like just be less hyperbolic and it
would be less obviously unbelievable and
I think that the the sort of key
reminder here is let's not take our eye
off the ball the the three key points
about the Russian bounty story are
number one they seem to have lied again
Trump was briefed or told about this in
some way shape or form multiple sources
and allegations that he was told either
in 2019 or February of this year or the
spring of this year or in all of those
instances that's number one that's
really important they lied again number
two the lies they told if true are only
indicative of other arguably just as big
problems like why wouldn't Trump have
been briefed about it number three Trump
was briefed and he still wanted Russia
back in the g7
to make at the g8 he still withheld arms
from Ukraine that they would have used
to defend themselves against Russian
aggression that's absolutely crazy and I
guess number four I said it was three
things but there's four Trump has
certainly been briefed by now right we
know now he's been briefed so now the
question is what is he going to do about
it now that he's been briefed and with
outed out knows about it and the answer
is nothing Trump actually tweeted this
morning I don't have to tweet handy but
he essentially tweeted he doesn't
believe the story like he's just
dismissing the story despite the fact
that we have officials of all kinds
saying it's a credible story it's a real
story it's a story we should believe so
that's just as important Trump now has
been briefed doing something no he's not
doing anything
he's just dismissing the story as
completely fake those are the main four
points that we should be thinking about
again when we recognize the importance
of removing this terror as we get closer
and closer to November from a strictly
strategic perspective Joe Biden should
pick Elizabeth Warren as his vice
president I'm gonna make the case for
that now Joe Biden already committed to
choosing a woman to be his running mate
Joe Biden has been asked more and more
lately to select a woman of color we saw
senator Amy Klobuchar remove her name
from consideration saying Joe should
really pick a woman of color now I think
part of it was Amy Klobuchar was wrapped
up in the whole Derrick shavon fiasco we
won't revisit that now but I think that
played a role but in any case Amy
Klobuchar are dropping out and saying
Joe should really pick a woman of color
rather than me and that would be
powerful in its own way but from a
merely strategic point of view I believe
Elizabeth Warren actually makes the most
sense if you balance name recognition
how progressive the candidates being
considered are and the effect that the
choice would have on the electorate
based on polling that we have Elizabeth
Warren seems like clearly the right
selection to me now there's a lot of
talk about Kamala Harris a black woman
current senator from California Harris's
identity would be very powerful the
first woman VP also being a black woman
there's no doubt that would be very
powerful the problem is
Kamala Harris's prosecutorial record as
Attorney General in the state of
California and that is not likely to
pull in disaffected Bernie voters it's
not likely to appeal to the progressive
way
of the Democratic Party I don't believe
that the disaffected Bernie voters are
like this huge portion of the electorate
but this could be a very close race
particularly in some key states and
seeing a prosecutor of the failed war on
drugs being Joe Biden's VP will do more
damage I believe than the benefit of
Kamala Harris's identity as a woman of
color you then seem names seen names
thrown around like Stacey Abrams
now I like Stacey Abrams she was a
Georgia state rep she ran for governor
in Georgia in 2018 I don't believe she
has the experience nor the name
recognition to really help Joe Biden
very much I don't actually believe she's
a top candidate right now I think
there's a very small chance that she is
selected Joe Biden is also reportedly
considering Val Demmings a black
congresswoman from Florida and Michigan
Governor Gretchen Whitmer from Michigan
and there's an interesting case to be
made for either of them but it seems
very clear to me that Elizabeth Warren
after Bernie is the next most
progressive candidate that was in the
running in the Democratic primary in
2020 and she has the name recognition
and she has some important
accomplishments to her name including
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
when you talk about structural reform
and you look at Kamala Harris versus
Elizabeth Warren Warren is much closer
to being the structural change candidate
than Harris there's no doubt that Bernie
was these structural change candidate no
question about it but after Bernie it's
Warren it's not Harris and I think that
that will have an appeal that the other
candidates will not now to make this
point a different way Warren would
mobilize the group that Biden needs
Biden has 92% support from black voters
Biden is not as strong with the most
progressive piece of the electorate
that's who Warren helps the most with
and I don't think she hurts him with
black voters at all and in fact there's
a morning console poll that shows that
Warren would bring in more black voters
than even Harris would and even then
Stacey Abrams would which are very very
interesting and
and results that reinforce Warren being
the strongest pick so in short to put it
very simply Warren is the most
progressive highly known person being
considered and in the polls
she helps Biden the most not only with
the most progressive voters but also
with black voters so that's who I would
go with now that being said there are
all sorts of ancillary reasons to focus
in on a woman of color instead of a
white woman I I don't deny that for a
second there is also a case that Biden
that Warren rather would be a strong
cabinet pick for Biden if she weren't VP
and she could be very strong as Treasury
secretary Secretary of Commerce other
possibilities but vice president would
be powerful and it would make an impact
right away Biden is reportedly going to
make his choice around August first so
we will see who it is one one just other
argument against Elizabeth Warren that
I've seen which is not it not a crazy
one is the argument that Warren is more
valuable in the Senate and that if she
leaves sometimes in Massachusetts in
these special elections we elect
Republicans to the Senate we saw it with
Scott Brown this is not a seat we can
afford to lose when we are looking to
take control of the Senate in the fall I
don't know if it'll happen it's an
uphill battle so that that would be an
argument against Elizabeth Warren but it
would be great to watch or destroy Mike
Pence in those debates wouldn't it so my
choice
is Elizabeth Warren I want to hear from
you here's a voicemail that came in our
voicemail number is a two one nine to
david p a voicemail about masks orders
let's take a listen to it David I wanted
to see what your thoughts were with
mandatory masks orders just in general a
few cities have started enacting them
and I was curious if we should see that
at the state level and what kind of
punishment should be levied assuming
people violated them okay
so first let's talk about the legal
basis there is a legal basis for masks
orders no question about it
remember that whole states rights power
of the states thing that a lot of
Republicans like to talk about this
falls under that a
federal nation wide mask order from the
federal government would actually be
legally dubious state and local
governments have pretty broad authority
particularly during a public health
emergency so I believe that the legal
case for a statewide or citywide mask
order is not legally problematic inside
of businesses businesses remember
Republicans wanted this stuff businesses
have broad authority within their
businesses and they can also say you've
got to wear a mask to be in my business
but I feel like it's the wrong focus the
reality is I don't think this should
come down to legality it comes down to a
legal question because so many people
just don't want to wear a mask we know
they're very very effective what this
should come down to is doing the right
thing because we want to fix this and we
want to take care of the people around
us and we want to take care of our
communities so if you make this a legal
argument I believe that cities and
states are very very comfortably able to
legally put in place masks orders I hate
that it's even a question we should be
doing it because it's just the right
thing to do we've got a great bonus show
today we will talk about what was a
closer than expected race in the
Kentucky Republican Senate Amy McGrath
officially winning against Charles
Booker we will talk about that we will
talk about the South Pole warming at
three times the global average over the
last 30 years horrifying stuff and we
will also discuss Mississippi dropping
its Confederate themed flag all of those
stories and more on the bonus show don't
miss it become a member at join
pakman.com to get instant access